S c i e n c e .
I
LOVE
SCIENCE!
No, no, no, no, no! I don't just looove scienlence.
Sci... Fuck you.
I
F U C K I N G
L  O  V  E
S   C   I   E   N   C   E   !
My name is PeeewDiePiiie!
Rick and Morty is my favorite anime. I freakin' love science!
Christian Channel. And, Neil Degrasse Tyson is my god.
[epic music]
If you've seen the legendary meme:
*demonstrates previously referenced meme*
This, have you've seen this meme?
[epic music]
Of course you have. It's a classic. One of my personal- Actually, it's my favorite meme of all time. I have it printed here on my
wall. Then, you might know of the legend, the one and only, Neil Degrasse Tysoooon.
*Katy Perry being dumb*
[Rage]
Because, I love science and I love Neil Degrasse Tyson, in case that wasn't clear before.
*cringe groaning*
I love science, seriously!
Neil Degrasse Tyson, that's my shit! He's my jam! I'm like Neil, feed it to me! Feed me the science back, man!
*pewdiepie eating sounds*
You need me to explain Rick and Morty to you Neil?
Science Facts: Pluto's not a real planet!
*sounds*
Science Facts left and right! You probably seen Neil already from my video where I did a Katy Perry.
[THE LEGEND] Most people who could be born will never be born. Will never even exist.
So, the fact that- [A KATY PERRY] Like, sperm?
Neil Is sort of an
evangelist for science, you know? It's his job.
It's his career. He built a career. He's an astrophysicist, but his main career seems to be, these days, to promote
science to people. Get people involved with silence- science. Why can I- Why do I mix that word up.
So, he goes on these celebrity tours. He goes on a lot of public appearances.
And, you know it's, it's a noble cause. It's a good thing, you know? Get people Involved with science. I have no problem with that.
But, you get, you get funny moments of, of people wanting to
understand science, But, they're just-
They're just idiots.
[THE ONE AND ONLY] So, the fact that-  [idiot] Like, sperm?! [SCIENCE GOD] Sure, yeah, yeah. [idiot] Well, it is science!
[KING OF SCIENCE] The rest don't. [the other one] Where do they go? [KING] They're dead!
There's also the famous one
where he
talks about time
with Pharrell Williams. And, time is such an interesting concept to me. Like, I really- That is one of those things that-
It's almost scary just to think of the concept of time and just
because, it's something infinite. You would think that's what they talk about in this, in this interview with,
with Tyson and Pharrell Williams, because he has this meme where he goes like, 'BAOWWAOA!'
And, maybe you've seen it.
[NDT] So, the sun would rise and set and we'd call that a day. The moon would go around
once, we call that a moonth, became a month.
Earth would go around the sun, that became a year and these became the natural
timekeeping ways.
When you want it to be more precise than just sun up and sun down,
you had to invent some machine that could keep more accurate time and it'd divide the day
into parts that are convenient to you.
[PeeeewDiePiiiie] Look at Pharrell! He's so ready
to have his mind blown. He's like, 'Oh My God! It's coming. It's coming! The science fact is coming! Come on, Neil feed it to
me! Feed me the science fact!
[NDT] We- That's- So, we now keep better time than that. We keep atomic time.
[Ph] Mhm.
[Guy In Top Left Corner] Look at, l-look at Pharrell's fucking face when he says that, 'We keep atomic time.'
[NDT] We- That's- So, we now keep better time than that. We keep atomic time. [Ph] Mhm.
So, now we use- It's an atomic clock and we can and you want
To have totally abandoned Clock is Really Based on like Atoms oh?
Yeah so Now you bring the clock into space and you don't you, no longer have to Read out this Jack
It's Actually Based on electrons Moving Within The Atoms Just to be precise i
Don't know What Frequency that is
How Annoyed neil gets from This he's Just like shut the hell Up dude i don't know What Frequency that is didn't even Say Anything
interesting he Just Explained
Atomic Clocks Is the Thing he didn't Explain How it works
It's Just Like We Use them to tell time it'S more accurate Than the sun in the stars
Look Even Poison out Himself
So you'd bring an Atomic clock with you and you'd Keep Good time and you're good to go yeah you are you're honking you don't
Have to sister Got It he's Got to digest this back Wow
you Just Blew my Mind
What that Atomic time is kept By Atomic clocks
Wow you Just blew my Mind Just blew my Mind like What Why
That Atomic time is Kept By Atomic clocks That's enough for you to be fuckin Mind
Blown on a Grid you might think of It is
What's street in New York What street What Haven't you and What floor in a Building that you might meet someone these are three
Coordinates That You It Would Not give a time Without a Place
Nor would you give a Place Without a time to meet someone require four Numbers
Basically four coordinates three Space Coordinates at One time time is the fourth Dimension
Isn't that a lot more interesting Than Just Saying This machine With Houses Atoms in its name in it uses atoms to explain Tap
Wow
so and This all This This Reaction That Farrell Has sort of Stems from This
New cult or Should i Say or new
Movement That
Embraces science as
It's Kind of Like Weed science like Whoa my Mind is totally Blown Right Now by these
Science facts Man I don't know what to do
There's These Websites Like i Fuckin love science oh i love science so much no you don't
you Like to look at Pretty Pictures or political pictures of Neil degrasse Tyson with quotes on it
31,000 People Liked This picture
This Little Cartoon Image Of an asteroid 400 People Like This Actual science article you know that cringe meme
With Neil Where he's Just like oh the crunch is too
strong It's for you okay you Just don't understand It he's Correct Neil's That Neil is Cringing at you
okay i think this comic strip Really
Explains The Whole i fucking love science Thing Perfectly did you know that Human Hair and Nails are made from the same Kind of Stuff
yeah i
Love science
I'm not Really sure you understand love or science When you love something you don't Just love the exciting and fun parts You love the
Boring Parts Just As Much As People Who truly love science Spend Their life studying the
Tedious Little Bits As Well as The big Flashy facts you don't love science you're looking at The butt When he walks By
Now don't Get me wrong i love neil i think he's a Very interesting person he looks like a Cute little?
Cuddly Teddy Bear and i Think he Generally Does a Really Great Job at explaining
complicated Things to an easy digestible
Way i think that takes a Great Skill and i have a Lot of respect for That
But there are times that neil gets It wrong
At least in my opinion Neil Is a Very Avid on Twitter
He posted in 2010 2010 another thought to disturb a restful Slumber
especially If You are Vain in a Mirror you can Kiss Yourself Only on the lips
4 months later:
*reading tweet*
I feel like I heard that before sometime. Three years later:
*reading 1st tweet*
(you know what's going on)
But, as someone was quick to point out; we have people living in space stations.
There's always someone in space.
Constantly. I hate this sort of approach that [Whine Voice] ugh things are better back before.
Things were better before, man.
45 years ago, things were way better, man. [Normal Voice] What about the internet, Neil?!
You know the thing that you tweet from? Do you remember before the internet? I do.
It was awful. I understand what he meant was the development of NASA and, and in space, but come on, man.
We're living better off than ever!
Don't be so down, Neil. You need a hug? I'd hug you. You look very huggable. Call me. (I ship it.) Let's see what Neil else tweets.
Bats are, in fact, not blind, Neil! I thought you loved science, Neil? Is that a-
Is that a science blown fact for you there?
* Pharrell Mind Blown Meme *
I thought you were better than this.  And, you know what? So what, Neil makes a few mistakes. That's fine.
Everyone does. I mean I never do I never Say anything Wrong okay
Ever has never Happened i think that What a noise is so much is that the internet has collectively decided to suck Neil's dick
so hard That he's Just become This Evan Evan Gallus of science it's Almost like science Is a
New Religion and Neil is the pope
He has a Closer Connection to science and most People and
When he Speaks science he speaks It in a Way that you don't understand You Simple average Joes You don't understand science like i do
magnemite neil degrasse Tyson
Man Am i Dead you got Dasom how how would to Ferry Traveled The World That quickly and how
Would She Possibly know who lost a Tooth it's not Just wrong but
Ignorant Thank you neil
God Darn It Finally Someone
scientifically
intelligent That can disprove This
Incorrect Theory Of The Tooth Fairy
But Stay The Hell away from Santa Neil okay because we Know that scientifically proven the tooth Fairy Nath's is wrong That's Just Ignorant
Ah i hate ignorance i'm Neal huh there's a Thing like i said i Really like nia i think it's really entertaining and
I think Is an interesting guy to listen to i think his Mission to
Speak for science Is noble i Just don't like
This i love science
Seriously i think Neil degrasse tyson is the shit and i think That's a Consequence of?
The Kind of science That he's promoting Along With Other websites personally i Hated Math and i Hated Physics Through
Through The Beginning of High School But Then i learned to love It because and not Because of stupid memes about
Space and things to blow your mind but because i find that it's really
Really Satisfying to do
Problem-Solving Like Math and it's really Really Fun and Satisfying to understand have a Deeper Understanding?
How Things Work in the universe and not Just Superficial
Atoms
Atom clocks are based off atoms. Whooaaa!! And, I just don't understand why can't you teach that instead. I really wish I learned
how fun math and physics and science can actually be when I was younger.
Rather than having to discover it by chance later. And, it's not gonna happen
through these stupid Facebook pages. Also,
Neil! Feel free to hit me up in the DMs, anytime! I-I'll go gay for you and Marzia gave me a free pass. *wink*